you know what song was hard that not a
lot of people are talking about is the
record on the burner album
crazy shout out wow burn it man that's
my bro he put a lot of people on a song
because mozzie was on that right yeah
shout out to mazzy mozzie's on that
record
it's funny because i like i know uh
benny and mozzie were on like a damien
lillard remix together
but i always told
me benny i was like dude i just want to
hear you and mazzy like really get down
on some [ __ ] like i was like man bernard
really ann are the [ __ ] out of that
record yeah burner is is too ill with it
man you know
i think you know a lot of that should
get kind of overlooked for sure because
he's so successful with
his other endeavors
like it's music
it's hard every tape everything he
dropped man is [ __ ] man shout out to
my bro and he be he's a good dude he
showed me there's so much love i didn't
have to i ain't going from a can of
paint
and you know i was saying
i wanted me got you want to get you want
some [ __ ] got me on some [ __ ] with
pusher
and then next you know someone mad and
this [ __ ] and all that yeah kids and
[ __ ] play video games like that [ __ ]
just ever since then i just been like
kind of just forever grateful
you guys are like i feel like you look
like zelda um all three of y'all and
bernie have a similar work ethic when it
comes to putting out music just catalog
like burn up [ __ ] around and drop four
albums in a year two of them will be
collab albums with like currency or
dolph or god rest all soul you know but
um
i feel like y'all have similar work
ethics and just on the independent [ __ ]
like man a lot of times it could be
[ __ ] on some lazy [ __ ] as artists and
then a lot of times too is everybody
don't be having the freedom to kind of
release when they want especially if
they're on a major yeah everybody you
know it's the beauty of being you know
kind of weak when you can do what you
want
burner can do what the [ __ ] you want to
do you drop five albums this morning if
you want